Narrator: It's been 10 years
since "Shark Tank"
ignited America's
entrepreneurial spirit,
and we're still blazing a trail.
For those who take their fate
into their own hands
by working hard...
We cracked the code
to the perfect soup.
‐...by working smart...
‐When it comes to investing,
nothing's hotter right now
than cryptocurrency.
Narrator:
...by thinking big...
I opened my first one
in 2012.
Now we are
all over Manhattan.
Narrator:
...and chasing their dreams...
Our dad invented
the Cup Board Pro,
and it was his dream
to pitch it on "Shark Tank."
...and tonight,
co‐founder of RSE Ventures
and Vice Chairman of the
Miami Dolphins, Matt Higgins,
joins the Tank.
We're gonna make this
a very big company.
I can help you get into
airports and stadiums.
Don't take any encouragement
from Matthew.
‐Well, I disagree.
‐That's on a soup business!
No soup for you!
Narrator: First in the Tank is a
convenient way to eat healthier.
♪♪
Hi, my name is Sara Polon,
and I am the CEO
and co‐founder
of Soupergirl.
And I'm
Marilyn Polon,
Sara's mom, CAO ‐‐
Chief Anxiety Officer.
[ Laughter ]
We're here
from Washington, D. C.,
and we're asking
for $500,000
for 10% of our company.
‐Oh.
‐Wow.
Sharks,
as most of you know,
most commercially
available soup
is not as healthy
as you might think.
I mean, why do need a PhD
to read the ingredient list?
I mean, really, Sara,
what is gwe‐ar gum...
What?
...monosodium glutamate...
Huh?
...and mechanically
separated chicken?
I don't even know.
[ Grumbling ]
Okay, at Soupergirl,
we have cracked the code
to the perfect soups.
Our soups are all‐natural,
they are hand‐crafted,
brimming in plant‐based
protein and fiber,
and really, really low
in salt and fat,
and they're bursting
in fresh vegetables.
Mmm.
Everything your doctor says
you should be eating,
and the soups
are delicious.
Yeah.
The proof is in the numbers ‐‐
my numbers!
My cholesterol
used to be 220,
and now it's
170 and dropping.
Good for you.
Sharks, what started off
as a small,
local,
soup‐delivery business
has organically grown
into something much bigger,
and now it's time
for the rest of the country
to be eating our soups.
You guys ready for this?
You want to try some soup?
You want to try
some soup?
‐Absolutely.
‐Come on. Bring it on.
‐Let's do this.
‐Yeah.
We've got
some great soup for you.
‐Bring it on.
‐Okay, sir.
‐Thank you.
‐You're welcome.
Okay,
so what we have here
is our chilled watermelon
gazpacho in the bottle,
we also have a West African
peanut stew,
we have our summer
minestrone,
curried
red lentil peach...
Mmm.
...and we have an
Indian‐style mulligatawny.
Mmm.
The ‐‐ The curried peach
is fantastic.
‐Thank you!
‐It's great.
What's your background?
Well, we have been
doing this since 2008.
Back in 2008, I was
a former stand‐up comic...
You were?
...looking for
a good bowl of soup.
Something that hopefully didn't
have a ton of salt and fat,
and I failed miserably.
So, obviously, I dragged my poor
mother out of retirement.
Yeah, so, let me ‐‐
I'll tell you the real story,
how this started.
Okay, she ‐‐
she does this sometimes.
You mean she's been lying to us
all the time?
No, but I ‐‐ I was in there
from the beginning.
So, let me tell you.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
Um, Sara wanted to st‐‐
‐Go ahead, Bubbe.
‐By definition, yep.
‐She's a great bubbe.
‐I can tell.
I think the problem started
when we launched
and I found
our first kitchen.
She said to me, "Ma,
I got this great kitchen
we're gonna cook in."
It was a dungeon,
literally a dungeon.
You had to go downstairs.
There was no air‐conditioning
in the summer.
We were shvitzing
in the winter.
‐She was shvitzing.
‐You were shvitzing? Shvitzing?
There was no heat!
I heard a squeak, squeak!
It was a mouse!
And I said,
"I am out of here."
‐Oh, no!
No, no, put it in the soup!
It's protein!
‐Ohh. We're plant‐based.
‐No, they're gonna get to that.
So, I said ‐‐ I said,
"Sara, I am out of here."
She said, "No, you're not.
You're staying,"
and I stayed,
because Sara is so determined.
And so I stayed.
I've been here for 10 years.
But, um ‐‐
‐Congratulations.
The product is really good,
so you passed the first test.
‐Thank you. Thank you.
‐However...
Yes.
...now we get down
to the numbers,
and quickly, I must say,
$500,000 for 10%
imputes a $5 million
business.
Oy.
‐Oy!
‐Yes.
‐Okay?
Now, I love the soup,
but you better sell
a lot of it.
So give me the sales.
‐Well, let's talk about 2016 ‐‐
$1.4 million.
‐Whoa!
‐Sales in 2017 ‐‐
$2.4 million.
There you go.
Whoa!
We're on track to do
$3.4 million. We started off ‐‐
‐Okay, how are you doing that?
‐Wow.
‐How are you doing that?
‐Very good. Impressive.
We started off as a
small, local, delivery
business ‐‐ Thank you ‐‐
and now we have two retail
locations.
We're in almost 50
natural‐food locations
and 20 box stores.
The consumer demand for this
product is exploding, and ‐‐
What did you make last year
on that $2.4 million?
How much did you make?
Oh, about 5%.
Ouch!
I'll tell you why.
Because in 2000 ‐‐
Sara, honey, sweetie, poopsie,
those are terrible margins.
You're grow‐‐ Look, you can't be
growing that fast.
We hit our capacity,
and I had to make
a decision.
Am I gonna stay where
we are as a small,
local‐D. C. business...
Get a copacker!
...or...
I'll tell you why
we can't get a copa‐‐
Or are we going to take this
nationwide?
And here's how we're very
quickly going nationwide.
Meet the Souper Meals
Program.
Okay? What we do is...
Oh.
...we deliver three‐day
or five‐day programs.
So, the three‐day
has 12 soups,
and the five‐day
has 20 soups.
Ohh.
So heavy!
People eat soup
all day every day?
Well, or ‐‐ or you can
customize the program.
You have this program
running?
We've run it
on a small level.
We've done about
$900,000 in sales.
I know that model.
I ship stuff in jars
all across the country.
I know you do.
Well, let me tell you
what it costs.
How much?
For the three‐day program,
it costs $50 to make
and we sell it for $99,
and that includes shipping.
That's not
a good margin.
Here's the tragedy
about to happen.
Let her finish.
No, no, look,
numbers are numbers.
Let her finish.
Let me get
the numbers out.
You made $120,000,
a 5%, okay, on the $2.4 million.
Yeah.
You priced the business
at a $5 million valuation.
Sara, that's a 41 multiple
on a soup business!
No soup for you!
[ Laughter ]
Sara, on the planet Earth,
during the planet's history,
has anybody ever paid
41 times for soup?
How do you know that?
I know that
because I know everything.
Okay, so ‐‐
And there's no way you're gonna
get that in here today.
Here's the ‐‐ Here's the ‐‐
Here's the thing...
Do you believe
that you're gonna, um,
net more...
Take over the ‐‐
...and increase more
than 5% for your net?
Oh, yes.
My fixed costs
are quite high
because of
this new kitchen.
Well, that goes back
to the copacker.
You were gonna say why didn't
want to use a copacker.
Right, okay,
so there's two reasons why we
don't want to use a copacker.
Number one, we're certified
Kosher, and you will not find ‐‐
‐There are Kosher copackers.
Not that can do this quality.
Trust me, we've talked to them.
So, Sara, you ‐‐ you won't let
your baby go...
But the reason ‐‐ the reason ‐‐
...because you think
you're the only person
that can make this quality...
Yes.
...and that's
costing you 5% to 6%.
Soup is horrible when they're
cooked in that quantity.
But they'll adjust for you if,
you know, if ‐‐
They'll let you be there
as they put in
those giant colanders.
But they're
doing it wrong.
Nobody does this.
Nobody does
what you're trying to do.
Exactly!
Do you have any, uh,
loans or debt?
Yes, I have $640,000 in
a small business loan
that I'm paying down.
Cuban: You see what's
happening here, right?
You keep on needing cash.
Yes.
And you're hoping that
you'll make it up in volume.
You have retail stores and
you have subscription, right?
When I see somebody going after
that many outlets,
that means they're not
completely confident in any one.
[ Stammers ]
Higgins: Wait, Sara.
I want ‐‐ I want to hear
a little bit about how you're
gonna use that $500,000.
Let's set aside the fact
that your valuation
is ridiculously high.
The website that
we're building ‐‐
Everything
that we've learned
from, uh, our
Souper Meals program
that we've done
over the past year,
we're gonna integrate it
into that website.
So, auto‐renewal, subscriptions,
refer‐‐ automated referrals.
It already exists.
You don't need to develop that.
And how much do you
think you're gonna have
to pay to get that done?
Yeah.
‐About $100,000.
‐No.
‐That's about right.
That's about right.
And then I want $400,000
for equipment,
to optimize my staff costs.
I mean, I need to bring
down my staff costs.
Y‐You're buying more equipment?
But how's that gonna now ‐‐
How's that gonna show up
in top‐line and bottom‐line?
Oh, sure, because my staff costs
are going to come down.
I ‐‐ My staff costs
are still too high.
Sara, you are literally at risk
of going out of business...
...and I don't think you realize
and know it.
Sara, you are literally at risk
of going out of business...
...and I don't think you realize
and know it.
You see what's
happening here, right?
You keep on needing cash.
You are so
capital‐intensive, right?
Yes.
Perfection is the enemy
of profitability.
I'm out.
I appreciate
all your feedback.
‐You're welcome.
‐Gave me a lot to think about.
O'Leary: So how much cash do
you have in the bank right now?
Mm, about $20,000.
‐Ohh!
‐Whoa.
‐Well, that's okay.
Wait, but no ‐‐ But in accounts
receivable, I have ‐‐
No, it's not okay.
You have to service right now
$640,000 of debt.
The business is worth
about $750,000 right now,
less the debt.
So it's worth about $100,000
and, you know, change.
That's the truth.
That's what a buyer
would give you for it.
I'm out.
You would have to do
$100 million
to make $5 million.
I would get 10% of that.
You would have to do
$100 million
just for me to get back
$500,000.
I mean, think about that.
For that reason, I'm out.
Higgins:
Sara, first of all,
I think we're being way too dire
about your business.
No.
I would never count you guys
out, all right?
‐Thank you.
‐You're gonna do $3.4 million.
You obviously have a sense of
what it is to sell your product,
but I don't think at the moment
it's a big business
and I can get
a big return on it.
So for those reasons,
I'm out.
I appreciate that.
Matthew, why are you
encouraging her on? You
know the model's broken.
Well, you know why?
You know why? You know why?
‐You know the model's broken.
‐So, I'm ‐‐ I'm encouraging
because I think, at the end
of the day, I think they're
gonna figure it out.
Don't take any encouragement
from Matthew.
There's more percentage
likelihood ‐‐
Are you ‐‐ I know. Are you
gonna ‐‐ Are you gonna leave ‐‐
leave the show and reflect
about whether or not
to go with a copacker?
Sure, I'm go‐‐ absolutely
gonna reflect.
But you'll
never do it.
And she won't do it.
You won't do it.
‐Are you in? Lori's still in.
‐I don't want you to take
any encouragement
from Matthew's comments
'cause you still have a 50/50
chance of going zero, okay?
I hate when he says
that, but in this case,
he might be right.
Lori, what do you have to say?
Okay.
I think the Soupergirl logo
and name is fabulous.
Thank you!
It's very cute.
It's very memorable.
There's one thing that,
for me, is not great.
5% profit margin.
Our profit margin
used to be much bigger.
But when we opened up
this new facility,
of course it went down,
but it is ‐‐
But ‐‐ But the problem is ‐‐
‐You're making her point.
‐But that's a huge problem.
Great soup,
but as an investor, I'm out.
♪♪
‐Good luck, guys.
‐Thank you.
‐Good luck.
‐Thank you!
‐Good soup, though.
‐Appreciate the feedback.
‐Thank you.
Thank you.
It's very delicious.
See you, Bubbe.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Sara: The soups
need to be perfect.
A Soupermom and Soupergirl
stand behind
every unit of soup
that goes out the door,
and that's never gonna change.
I don't ‐‐
Seriously, she's in trouble.
No, but entrepreneurs
do that all the time.
The soup was really good.
Perfection, perfection. Only I
can do it. Only I can do it.
You know what this was?
This was dead soup boiling.
♪♪
I was born and raised
in Queens, New York,
raised by a single mother
in a little apartment
with three brothers.
Grew up really poor.
And when I say "poor,"
I mean really poor.
My earliest memories
of a gourmet meal
was what I'd call
government cheese.
It was a long box of cheese
that would arrive
and literally said "government
cheese from the USDA."
My mother always had
a variety of health issues.
Eventually, she ended up
in a wheelchair.
I made a decision
at a very early age
that I wasn't gonna let poverty
dictate the rest of my future.
When I was 16, I decided to drop
out of high school.
Everyone said,
"You're gonna ruin your life,"
but I knew
that if I could get my G. E. D.
and go to college as fast
as humanly possible,
I could accelerate my path
out of poverty.
I was working during the day,
I would take classes at night,
and I'd go home
and take care of my mother.
After college, I started working
for the city of New York,
and I would attend classes
at night
to get my law degree
at Fordham.
At 26 years old,
I was appointed Press Secretary
of New York City.
I finally thought everything
was gonna be okay.
I had enough money to take care
of my mother,
and on my first day of the job,
my mother died.
I regret that my mother never
got a chance to experience
the benefits of the life
that I've created.
I was Press Secretary
during the worst
terrorist attack in history.
I became
the Chief Operating Officer
of the agency
in charge of rebuilding
the World Trade Center site.
The greatest professional honor
of my life
was to be involved
in the rebuilding effort.
It would become a defiant symbol
of resiliency for New York
and for the country.
In 2004,
I got an amazing opportunity
to join the New York Jets,
and over the next eight years,
I held a number
of different jobs,
from helping build
a new stadium
to, ultimately, overseeing the
business operations of the team.
After a great run
at the New York Jets,
I decided
that I was gonna take the leap
and become an entrepreneur,
and that's when I teamed up
with Steve Ross
and started RSE Ventures.
And now I'm the CEO
of RSE Ventures
and the Vice Chair
of the Miami Dolphins.
Hey!
I don't invest in ideas.
Ideas are cheap.
I invest in people,
special people,
who have what it takes to take
that idea and go the distance.
You come to visit me, and it's
like, "Ooh, okay, let's go!"
Everybody needs something.
We like to think
we're the missing component,
so we bring
our real‐estate expertise,
our sports expertise,
our technology expertise,
and we roll up our sleeves, and
we do whatever it takes to win.
The entrepreneurs
who go on "Shark Tank,"
they're trying to make it
and transcend,
and I relate to that.
I feel like my whole life
has been about that.
It's not about where you began,
it's where you end up
and how much distance
you covered.
♪♪
Narrator:
Next up is a simpler way to
invest in the hottest new craze.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks!
My name is Dmitri Love,
and I'm from Dallas, Texas.
Yeah!
My company is Bundil.
I'm seeking $100,000
for 10% equity in my company.
When it comes to investing,
nothing's hotter right now
than cryptocurrency.
Everyone's talking about it,
but does anyone really know
what they're talking about?
Now, cryptocurrency
is a digital currency,
so investing in it
is a little different.
Now, you could mine
your own currency,
which is best done
with a dedicated mining chip.
Essentially, you're using
decentralized
blockchain technology
to track shares
and validate transactions
using a known algorithm.
These are then added
to the existing blockchain
using an ‐‐
an encryption technique
that controls the creation
of monetary units
and ultimately verifies
the transfer of funds.
[ Sighs ]
That's one way.
Or you could just use Bundil,
the most convenient way
to invest in cryptocurrency.
Bundil allows...
Oh, shoot.
The Bundil app allows, um...
users to automatically invest
their spare change every day
into, um, cryptocurrency.
The Bundil app controls...
Dude...
Higgins:
You're doing great.
You're good, Dmitri.
Cool, cool, cool.
Sorry about that.
You can start
anywhere you want.
And you look great.
Thank you, thank you.
Dmitri, this is the biggest
moment in your life.
‐Shut up, Kevin.
‐I agree. I agree.
Bundil is
a mobile application
that allows you to invest
your spare change
from everyday purchases
directly into crypto.
Um, the app, uh, automatically
tracks your spending habits.
So, if you were to go buy
this coffee for $3.45,
the 55 cents would
be rounded automatically
and invested into the
cryptocurrency of your choice.
Um...
you don't need thousands
of dollars to start investing.
Just keep doing
what you're doing,
leave the complicated math
and algorithms behind,
and Bundil will take care
of the rest.
So, which one of you wants
to hop on board with Bundil
and make bundles of cash?
‐[ Chuckles ] Yay.
‐All right.
Good, uh ‐‐
Good finish there.
Do you think, um,
you could possibly...
Yeah.
...simplify
what is cryptocurrency?
You'd be breaking
entirely new ground
if you could explain it.
Oh, for sure.
So, it's just like money
and, in a small way,
kind of like stocks.
It's like money in that you can
use it for purchases of ‐‐
uh, for services and goods.
Um, it's like stocks because,
um, the value fluctuates.
Dmitri, why don't you give us
a little insight
into, uh, what gave you
this idea?
I'm a web developer myself,
and I wanted to invest
in cryptocurrency,
and my family
also wanted to invest,
so they came to me and
they're like, "Dmitri,
how do we buy this?
Like, what do we do?"
So I thought,
I was like, "Man, you know,
anyone that's trying to invest
in cryptocurrency
has to go through all
these steps,
um, to try and figure out
how to buy it,"
and I thought there could be
an easier way for it to be done.
Which cryptos
does it support?
Uh, so right now,
it only supports, uh,
Bitcoin, Ethereum,
and Litecoin.
How does Bundil
make money?
We charge a monthly fee
of $3 a month,
or, if you pay
for the entire year, it's $24.
So, start us ‐‐ start me
from the beginning.
Okay.
I download the app.
So, right now,
we only have, um,
a minimum viable product.
We did our soft launch
about 60 days ago.
We have an iOS app, um,
the web app is almost completed,
and we're working on Android
as we speak.
O'Leary: Why are you going
to get market share?
What's ‐‐ What's special about
Bundil that is going to
take away share from the wallets
that already exist?
So, the "set it and forget it"
mentality
is very popular
among micro‐investment users.
There are a few competitors
in the space that have done
really, really well with the
micro‐investment technology.
I'm in the
financial‐services industry.
I also have apps that do
the same thing this does.
Not crypto, but I do
fractional‐share ownership
in an app called Beanstox.
Mm‐hmm.
Here's what we learned
about the space.
Most apps fail within 36 months
over 80%
because they're never
able to get the customer
acquisition cost
below the lifetime value.
How are you gonna
get customers?
Um, so, we can actually
advertise on Facebook.
That is one big thing.
That's a very expensive way
to acquire a customer.
Yes.
Far better would be a viral
approach, a blog approach,
an influencer approach, and
all of the above simultaneously.
It's really, really hard.
So, our customer
acquisition costs
are actually only
$2.77 right now.
‐How do you know that?
We have about 360 users,
and we've put $1,000
into marketing ‐‐
yep, just the monthly.
Greiner: Dmitri,
I know for some people,
they think cryptocurrency
is just the wave,
or going to be the wave.
Yeah.
Um, for me,
I'm not so sure.
I'm still on
the crypto fence,
so I'm out.
Okay. Thank you.
Yeah, Dmitri, I mean,
I always try to help out
Dallas entrepreneurs.
[ Chuckles ]
Challenge here is I'm
an investor in a company
called ChangEd, which,
as you know, i‐is comparable
in a lot of ways, so...
Definitely.
...for those reasons,
I'm out.
Thank you.
I think, uh, the digital
currency space is here to stay,
but it's still just
the wild, wild west.
Yeah.
So, it's very volatile,
it's unregulated.
Definitely.
So I think it's a little
too early for me.
I'm out.
Okay.
Thank you.
O'Leary: Dmitri, what I like
about this is it falls into
my financial literacy
platform.
I've been
crisscrossing America,
lecturing on Saturdays
at colleges
about how important it is
to take a portion of your pay,
or whatever your income source
is, and invest it.
Here's my offer.
So, I'll give you $100,000,
I want to be a 50% partner,
and I'll tell you why.
You are going to be stunned
at how expensive it is
to acquire customers, and I have
the metrics on this nailed,
and we'll have to put up
more money as time passes.
Can you commit to putting up
money as time passes?
If it's working.
I pour gasoline,
I put millions of dollars
into my financial platforms.
Millions.
Dmitri, one of the big
frustrations I have
with Bitcoin is...
Oh, you bet‐‐
...that there still
isn't any use for it
from a consumer standpoint,
right,
ever since that guy bought pizza
with 10,000 Bitcoins.
Dmitri, have you seen Kevin walk
away from deals before?
I have.
I think you should consider
partnering up
with different
token economies 'cause
they're sprouting up
all over the place.
You can piggyback off
their marketing machine
to go ahead and push your app.
After the regulators say yes.
After ‐‐
After they say yes.
But I like the idea
of you partnering
with all those different
token exchanges and saying ‐‐
That's a great way
to kill your business
while you're trying
to get it started.
Well, I disagree.
There are a few reasons why
it's just not for me.
I think it's too easy
to create a competitor,
there's too many similar
products already out there,
and it's just too early.
Um, it's not investable
in my opinion,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
‐Kevin ‐‐
‐Dmitri, just so you understand,
I'm either 50/50
or I'm nothing.
Your decision.
But 50% is quite a bit.
Well, Dmitri, I wouldn't look
a gift horse in the mouth.
It's a great opportunity
to take on all the hassles
you're struggling with.
O'Leary: This is the moment.
You have to decide if you
want me as a partner or not.
It's your decision.
It's a great offer,
Dmitri.
[ Inhales deeply ]
[ Sighs ] Kevin,
I'll accept your offer.
‐Yeah, smart move, Dmitri.
‐All right.
You made the right decision,
my friend.
You made
the right decision.
Appreciate it.
Let's go make it happen.
Sure.
I got a lot of work
for you, bud.
[ Laughing ]
He doesn't look happy.
‐He doesn't look so happy.
‐He doesn't look too happy.
‐[ Laughs ]
‐He made the ‐‐
He looks miserable.
Just launched my business
60 days ago,
and to have a Shark on board
is just a dream come true.
I can't believe it.
It's [laughing] amazing.
[ Laughs ]
He walked out like this!
Daymond and Mark,
you've got ‐‐
You've got to understand
something.
[ Laughter ]
I don't do good deals,
I do great deals.
Remember the cupcake lady?
Her daughter started crying
when they did a deal with you?
[ Laughter ]
And ‐‐ And today,
she's a millionaire.
♪♪
Narrator: Next into the Tank
is an artful twist
to a healthy dining concept.
♪♪
Hello, Sharks.
My name is Guy Vaknin,
and I'm the chef and owner
of Beyond Sushi.
I'm seeking a $1.5 million
investment in exchange
for 25% of our planned venture
on the West Coast
and 5% of our current operation
on the East Coast.
Beyond Sushi's a multi‐unit
vegan restaurant
operating in New York City.
We take a modern approach
to traditional sushi
by creating unique flavor
profiles using vegetables,
fruits, and whole grains
without relying on fake meats
while having a balance
between nutrition and flavor.
Our extensive menu
includes salads, wraps,
dumplings, and rolls.
We are one of the pioneers
of the vegan sushi movement
and creating a better,
healthier,
much more sustainable way
of eating.
Sharks, if you dive into
this deal with me,
there will be plenty of fish
for you guys to swim with.
[ Laughs ]
Do we get samples?
‐Yeah, let's eat!
‐Of course.
Yeah.
I brought you three of
our best‐seller rolls.
I'm hungry.
But then I'm always hungry.
Ah, this looks amazing.
Amazing.
Amazing!
Uh, we have the Mighty Mushroom,
which has four‐grain rice,
baked tofu inside shiitake,
enoki, micro arugula,
and a truffle...
Mmm!
‐Yeah, that's good.
‐...shiitake sauce.
Right next to it,
we have the Sunny Side.
It has braised fennel,
sun‐dried tomato, avocado,
roasted butternut squash,
and a pesto sauce on top.
So good.
Yeah, they're a little bit
more intricate.
That mushroom one
is the truth.
‐Mmm.
‐Thank you very much.
How do the calories compare
to normal sushi?
So, it averages, with the sauce,
at 280 calories.
‐For a roll?
‐For a roll.
And a roll
is eight pieces.
So it's about the same?
Yeah.
What does it cost
for eight pieces?
Okay, you can buy eight pieces,
which is one roll,
uh,
and it will cost you $7.50.
It costs me about
a buck 50 to make.
I love it.
So, we have six locations.
I opened my first one
in July 2012,
took all my life savings,
which was $70,000.
It had 12 seats and a counter
and one employee.
[ Chuckles ]
Now we are
all over Manhattan.
On our bigger units,
we do about $2 million a year.
Uh, and then when we do ‐‐
How many square feet
is the bigger unit?
It's big.
It's 2,500 square feet.
Wow. Great.
The first one I opened
was 280 square feet,
which I did a million dollars
out of.
‐Hmm.
‐Okay.
Wow!
And I have one that is
108 square feet
that I do $600,000 out of.
The whole idea of this, it's
a commissary‐based business,
so we have one big kitchen
that supplies everything.
A‐And the restaurants can be
as small as 600 square feet?
It can be as small as 250.
So, you're a grab‐and‐go
restaurant, right?
You're not a "sit here
and watch us make this"...
No, we're grab and go.
It's fast‐casual,
but we do have another model,
and that's the 2,500 square feet
that we opened recently.
And then what made you pivot to
this 2,500‐square‐foot model?
At the end of 2015,
I partnered up with, uh,
the founder
of Ruby Tuesday.
Sandy Beall, right?
Sandy Beall, yes.
Yeah, great guy.
He has 25% of the company.
And you have 75%?
75%, yes.
So,
when you talk about 25%,
that's of
the East Coast, right?
Yes.
And I'm guessing you own 100%
of the West Coast
because you haven't
really started it yet.
Yes.
Tell us, for the last year,
what your sales have been
and whether you're
profitable or not.
So, last year, we did
$4 million in sales.
What did you net on it?
So, last year was the year that
we made basically the change.
So, I took a commissary,
I opened two big locations,
so I was negative $272,000.
How much did you invest
last year?
I put $160,000 out of my own
pocket into the business
just to keep it running 'cause
we did lose money, right?
The year before that,
when we were doing $2.4 million,
I put in my pocket $600,000.
And we're projecting
$5.6 million for this year.
What will you make on the
$5.6 million, do you think?
This year, we're gonna make
around $300,000.
Higgins: Chef, I understand
this space really well.
Yes, yeah.
I have a number of
different investments ‐‐
&pizza, I'm actually
on a board with Sandy.
I heard, yes.
Yes.
So I know this space
very well.
I want to go
a little deeper.
Tell me what your average
cover side is.
Dinnertime,
we do about $22 a head.
Uh, at lunch time,
it's, uh, $15.
Okay, give me your traction.
How you been doing?
Have you been growing in covers?
Are you growing?
Oh, yeah.
So, we've been growing, like
I said, for the whole company,
I told you we were
$2,050,000.
The year before that,
we were $978,000,
so we doubled in size
in one year.
I want to go deeper.
Stay with me on the unit
economics, all right?
Yes. No problem.
So you know an ideal QSR?
Yep.
Or, you know, a fast‐casual
restaurant should be doing
20% profit
at the store level.
Yep. Uh‐huh.
Where are you right now
after how many years?
So, we're doing ‐‐
we're doing 20% on ‐‐
Well, I'm ‐‐
I'm ‐‐ I'm finding out a lot.
So, I know nothing about
that end of the retail.
Like...
Yes.
...Matt asked you ‐‐
What did you ask him?
What's his PR? QR?
QSR ‐‐
Quick Service Restaurant.
I had no idea what
any of that was,
and for that reason,
I'm out.
[ Laughs ]
Thank you.
I'm struggling with
a different problem.
I'm gonna make the assumption
you'll be as successful
on the West Coast as you were
on the East Coast.
Yes.
And you're going to generate,
after three years,
$5‐plus million
on the operations...
Yes.
...if the ‐‐ if the footprints
look the same.
Here's the problem
with this.
Yeah.
You're gonna make
$300,000 pre‐tax
on $5‐plus million
in sales.
Yes?
We agree?
I agree.
Okay.
I give you $1.5 million
to get 25% ownership
in the West Coast.
Okay.
I'm basically paying
20 times pre‐tax earnings.
I think you're insane.
Your valuation's insane.
I'm out.
Okay.
Chef.
Thank you.
What's the vision
for the brand, right?
In order for these
to be successful,
it has to be a strong,
sustainable vision
if not a fad.
Of course.
I want to hear a little bit
more about that.
It's not a secret.
I mean, you know it,
'cause you're in
the food business.
It's shifting towards
everything plant‐based,
everything healthier.
This is no imitation.
Everything that
you see over here
is fruits, vegetables,
whole grains, beans.
Cuban: Okay,
so wait, wait, wait.
You're not alone in doing
plant‐based sushi
and comparable plant‐based
other options.
The problem is here you are on
a mission on the East Coast,
which is hard enough.
Yes.
Then you want to do it again
and, you know,
I didn't see a clone anywhere
coming up in the pitch.
So, my gut's telling me no.
I'm out.
So, here's what I don't like
about the deal.
I don't like the
misalignment of the fact
that I'm getting 5% equity
in a concept
that already has
a lot of traction...
Here it comes.
...and then I'm paying
$1.5 million
for what may
or may not work.
We all intuitively feel
like you're gonna do great
out here, right?
But I don't know.
And I know you're gonna be
putting in as much time
in New York
as you are in L. A.
So there's a misalignment
between you and I
because I'm gonna want you
to spend all your time in L. A.
I need you to align
my interests
in L. A. and New York.
Okay.
How can you do better by
bringing those two together?
♪♪
Narrator:
Three Sharks are out.
Matt is interested in Guy's
plant‐based sushi business,
Beyond Sushi,
but he wants more of the
established East‐Coast business
than the current 5%
that Guy is offering.
I think that I can go
a little bit higher
in the one
that we have on the East Coast,
if that would
make the deal happen.
Eh...
How much higher?
♪♪
So, 10% is, uh ‐‐
is where I'll go.
All right,
here's what we got.
Yes.
Lori and I are gonna come in
to this deal together.
Okay.
We're gonna work together
to change your life.
We're gonna make this
a very big company.
Ugh.
Okay.
We're gonna cross‐market
like crazy.
I can help you get into
airports and stadiums
all over the country.
This is just up my alley
completely.
I think this will do
even better
on the West Coast,
personally...
I think so, too.
...because I think
that's the mind‐set here
is even more towards
this type of food.
So, you get both of us,
you get the entire network,
but I need to be incentivized
to work hard for you.
The offer on the table
is 30% in L. A.,
15% New York,
and you have a deal.
♪♪
You have three choices ‐‐
yes, no, or counter,
and you need to make them fast,
and you know why?
So I can eat
the rest of that sushi.
[ Laughs ]
Can we do 12% and 30%?
And at the end of the day,
guys, look,
as much as I gonna have
all the access in the world
and everything,
I'm gonna work.
That's what I did
with this company.
I built it. You guys,
I‐I worked three years.
I know.
I love your energy.
You have two Sharks,
and we're gonna work, too.
Yeah, and what's great is once
you become part of my family...
Yes.
...you get access to all
the different operators.
You want me to own enough
in New York to drive it as well.
That's a ‐‐
That's a waste if I don't.
I can feel your energy
and your intensity.
I love it.
But my offer's firm, all right?
You get both of us,
you get the entire network,
but I need to be incentivized
to work hard for you.
♪♪
Let's do it.
‐Yay!
‐All right!
Whoo!
‐[ Laughs ]
‐Thank you.
I'm so excited for you.
You're awesome.
I appreciate it.
‐Thank you very much.
Thank you.
‐Congrats, Guy.
Good job.
Congrats, man.
Ahh!
This was fun.
[ Exhales quickly ]
I really like that guy.
I knew he was gonna go far.
It was worth it to give up
a little bit more equity.
I got two Sharks, and we can
take all their knowledge,
and take the investment,
and just go light speed
to where we want to be.
For me, "Shark Tank"
taught me that anyone
can be an entrepreneur no matter
your situation or your age.
So don't make excuses
and just go for it.
♪♪
I'm Keira.
I'm Christian.
I'm Kaley.
And we're siblings
from Long Island, New York.
Our dad, Keith,
was a New York City fireman.
He was a firehouse chef.
Everyone always loved
his cooking.
Your father made the kitchen
a place to feel comfortable,
safe, and warm.
Keira: Our product was
designed by our dad
and is created to simplify
the way you work in the kitchen.
My dad was ready to introduce
his product to the world,
but he put everything on hold
when our mom was diagnosed
with stage 4
breast cancer.
She battled for two years
and lost her fight to cancer
on August 22, 2012.
That was the hardest day
of our lives.
Losing our mom was
really hard for our dad,
but we all really
just encouraged him
to make his dream
a reality.
But in 2015, he was diagnosed
with synovial sarcoma,
a cancer that developed
from being a fireman
in the cleanup of 9/11.
Our dad fought
as hard as he could,
but just three months ago,
our dad passed away.
Our dad's funeral was the
biggest tribute to who he was.
Over 1,000 people came.
The New York City
Fire Department
had the whole street
closed down,
and they just really honored
who our dad was as a hero.
I think that it's love
that keeps you strong,
and the foundation
that both our parents
set for the three of us
is what gets us through
each day.
The Sharks should invest in this
product because it's amazing,
and it has the support
of three really strong kids
who love the person
that created it.
♪♪
Hi, Sharks.
My name is Kaley Young.
I'm Christian Young.
I'm Keira Young.
Together:
And we're the Young family.
We're here today seeking
$100,000
in exchange for 10% equity
in our business.
Our business is...
Together: The Cup Board Pro.
Our dad invented
the Cup Board Pro,
and it was his dream to pitch it
on "Shark Tank."
Unfortunately, he passed away
before he had that chance.
Oh, I'm sorry.
But we're here today
to continue his legacy
and make that dream
a reality.
To tell you more
about our dad's invention,
here is a video our dad made
about demoing the Cup Board Pro.
My name is Keith Young.
I'm the inventor
of the Cup Board Pro.
Cup Board Pro is really,
really simple to use.
Open up your cup,
slide it in
to the tongue and groove
in the board.
I'm gonna cut an onion.
I'm gonna core it, I'm gonna
take all these scraps.
They're gonna go
right into the cup.
I didn't have to put a bowl
under my board.
I didn't have to stop.
Really couldn't be
any simpler.
It is so easy.
So, flip your board over.
I'm gonna use, like,
a cup of red wine
to simulate meat juices.
The routings are directing
the juice
to go right where
they need to be.
I'm not doing anything.
I'm a New York City
firefighter,
I'm a father, a widower,
cookbook author,
"Cooking With
the Firehouse Chef."
When I'm at home, I have to
get things done rapidly
because I have three children.
I'm a single parent now.
I have to clean, and on top
of that, I have to cook.
I need to kind of be
on my game with my kids.
Everything revolves around
my kitchen, really, at home.
That's where the heart of
a regular family's house is.
♪♪
We feel honored
to be here today
and to share a little bit
of Keith Young
and the Cup Board Pro
with you all.
So, who's ready to make our
dad's dream a reality with us?
That was very moving.
Thank you.
Your dad sounds like
an amazing guy.
Can you tell us a little bit
more about when he invented it
and give us a little more
of the story?
Yes. Um, my dad invented this
when I was in high school.
And then as he was getting
his first prototypes,
our mom was diagnosed
with breast cancer.
Cuban: Ohh.
And he put everything on hold
to be by her side.
I was 19 at the time.
My brother was 15,
and my sister was 9.
Um, on August 22, 2012,
God called my mom home,
and my dad just showed us what
strength was in every moment
that he continued
to show up for us,
and just in life
in general.
He was a true inspiration,
just like our mom.
And then, um, my dad took
a break with the Cup Board Pro.
He was asked to be on "Chopped,"
and he did it,
and he was a two‐time
"Chopped" champion,
which then gave him
the confidence
to start working
on this again.
In December, um, he got his
delivery of 2,000 boards,
and at that time,
he was diagnosed with cancer,
which was a 9/11‐related cancer
from being a fireman there.
And [voice breaking]
um, he was on hospice
in the beginning
of the year,
and he just passed away
three months ago.
I'm so sorry.
‐Thank you.
‐Wow.
Christian: So, we have ‐‐
we have this amazing ‐‐
amazing invention
right here for you guys.
We're gonna pass
you guys each one.
Lori: Great. Thank you.
♪♪
‐Here you go.
‐Thank you.
Ooh, it's heavy!
This is for you.
Kaley: It's ‐‐
My dad was all about quality.
So it's bamboo.
We have three patents
on the board and the cup.
The tongue and groove
is really important.
My dad has his fireman logo
on the board, and if you see,
it has the number of how many
firemen died on 9/11, so...
‐Oh. I didn't notice that.
‐Oh, wow.
‐Yep.
‐It's on the back?
It's something
that really honors
the fire department.
This board is really heavy,
really great quality.
Engineered smart.
So, this well,
no matter where you put it,
it's going to run ‐‐
the juices will run down
because it's pitched higher
in the back.
John: I love it, 'cause
that's usually the problem.
When you're cutting,
you have to push all the stuff
off to the side
here and there.
Right?
Many of them have a well
built into the board.
Yeah.
But here, you can take it off,
throw it in the dishwasher.
Yeah, 'cause when
you put the ones with the well
built in there, it doesn't fit
straight in the ‐‐
in the dishwasher.
Yeah, exactly,
it doesn't fit. Too tall.
It's an amazing product.
It's incredible.
Thank you.
So, what are your sales?
The three of us actually
just began
three weeks ago
selling the board.
'Cause you have 2,000
in inventory, right?
Yes.
Yeah.
Are you putting that
online?
We just launched our online
store three weeks ago.
How old are you?
I'm 24.
You're 24.
‐I'm 20.
‐20.
I'm 15.
So your dad wanted
to come on "Shark Tank"
before he passed away?
Yeah.
Yes, that was actually
his audition video.
And on 9/11, where was he?
Which part of the city?
He was part
of the clean‐up.
So, he was at ‐‐
he was there for that.
Okay.
And over 2,000 firemen
are actually currently sick
from 9/11 just
from all the fumes
that they were
breathing in, so...
Yeah, I was, um ‐‐ I was
at ground zero on 9/11,
spent two years there
during the clean‐up...
Oh, my gosh.
...working with the city
and I met a lot of brave people
like your dad and a lot of
people who lost their lives,
so it's great
that you're doing this.
Together: Thank you.
O'Leary: What are your ‐‐
What's your costs?
$12.50.
Okay, and you're selling them
on the site for?
$40.
How many have
you sold so far?
300 in the last
three weeks.
‐Good for you.
‐Wow.
How are you selling them? What
are you doing to market them?
Really great. How are you
getting that ‐‐ Yeah.
Um, just through social media
and our online store,
and then
in our living room,
we're all packaging
the boards together,
writing everyone individual
thank‐you notes.
Thank‐you cards.
You guys are real
entrepreneurs now, huh?
Yeah.
What's the money gonna be
used for, the $100,000?
Keira: We have to
renew our tooling,
and then for marketing
and advertising,
which is like $20,000,
and then, like,
all‐new cutting boards,
which would be around $50,000.
You mean, um, inventory?
Yeah.
So, are you running
the business basically ‐‐
the three of you together,
that's it?
Together: Yes.
‐You're running everything?
‐Yes.
Higgins: So, what ‐‐ So, what
overwhelms you right now?
Tell us why you're here
and what you're looking for
in a Shark to help you with.
Kaley: I think, honestly,
it's kind of hard
to overwhelm the three of us
just because of...
[ Chuckles ]
...like, the amount of stress
that you go through
just seeing
your loved one sick.
Um, and we're only
able to be here
because of how strong
our parents were.
You know what?
Is it possible for you
just step out
in the hallway for a second?
Sure.
Yeah.
Yeah, sure.
♪♪
Greiner: They have
inventory, right?
I could ‐‐
I could sell that off,
I feel, quickly
at QVC, right?
But they ‐‐ they want to
run a business.
We'll get there.
Oh, geez.
It's not that scary.
Well, I hope we get a deal,
and then we'll be fine.
[ Chuckles ]
So,
once this story's out,
obviously the units
they have will ship.
We just have to keep in mind
we need to take on
the new part
of the business,
the new mold,
the new inventory.
These have to made at a fraction
of what they're paying.
I would feel good with anyone
making an offer.
I feel like we're in a dream
right now.
You want to
call them back in?
Come on back!
♪♪
You know,
the story's amazing, right?
Obviously, you have
a‐a million reasons to be proud.
Thank you.
And your father
will live on forever
through each of you
and this product.
But rather than us
fight it all out,
we decided
to work together.
Wow.
And so all five Sharks
are gonna come together ‐‐
[ Laughter ]
Which is a rarity.
Now, we're Sharks,
so we're gonna negotiate.
In fact, it pretty well
never happens.
So, we're ‐‐ we're gonna
offer you a deal.
Okay.
$100,000 for 20%...
Now ‐‐ and each one of us
is gonna contribute $20,000
and our expertise so that
we can help you.
Mm‐hmm.
And so any profits
that we earn from our 20%,
we're gonna contribute
to whatever charity
your dad supported for firemen
that have been sick from 9/11.
‐Oh, my gosh.
‐That's our offer.
It's a deal!
[ Snaps fingers ] Yes!
It's a deal.
‐It's a deal.
‐It's a deal. All right.
‐Thank you so much.
‐Give me a hug.
Thank you so much, Daymond.
Thank you.
‐Congratulations.
‐Thank you.
Thank you, Lori.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
Now, we're still gonna
make you guys work.
Yes,
we're ready to work.
All right, 'cause I know
you're already hard workers.
So, it's not gonna be easy.
Don't worry.
We're not here for easy.
‐Congrats, guys.
‐Thank you so much, guys.
‐Thank you guys so much.
‐It's exciting.
‐Love you.
[ Laughs ]
Awesome!
Oh, my gosh.
That was amazing.
You know, this is the beauty
of entrepreneurship.
‐Yeah.
‐Yes.
They're gonna be able
to support themselves.
This is a product
that'll go on forever.
Higgins: I love it.
And the beautiful thing is,
is that they have each other.
Love you, guys.
Good job.
Kaley: Now that we have
all five Sharks on board,
we can really make
our dad's dream come true.
Our dad would probably be
so proud of us,
and, like, so happy that
we're continuing on his legacy,
his dream.
Bring it in.